[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up prof good day walter
hi what number are we at i think it is
number 25
25 okay you mustn't ask me so quickly
just put me on the spot here
let me open with a word of prayer then
we can get into it
our heavenly father we want to thank you
that we can get together again
thank you for giving us the opportunity
to do these discussions
we ask that you enlighten the viewers
and our minds with the holy spirit
and guide us in jesus name amen
do we continue with the saga of last
time
remember we called it conspiracy
theories
and some of it seems you know unreal
far-fetched and
yet somehow they form a pattern yes
and we spoke about our
uh view of why these strange predictions
occur we looked at the deagle
dot com and 2025.
by the way it's not just alisa bailey
that talks about
2025. as we said there are a number of
of movies that talk about 2025
there are numerous talk shows that talk
about
2025. now let's just again say that we
are not
time setting in any shape or form this
is just what these people are saying
the point is the devil knows something
and then we also spoke about demonic
interactions with humanity and
we mentioned that even some of the world
leaders
or many of them probably are
in communication either directly or
indirectly
with these entities now when we talk
about these world leaders
and some of their connections we
mentioned ronald reagan
and uh his
involvement in this kind of world
and bill clinton and hillary clinton and
we didn't talk about some of the others
but from my own personal experience i
know that this is the case
because those who know my testimony
when i was helping my father-in-law just
before his death
return all the esoteric books
to their source
let's put it that way to a specific
temple
then i helped him carry it in and
the channel for this continent that i
was on
thought i was one of them because i was
with my father-in-law
and i remember i was there and my son
was there
and i said to him to my son
we have to pray we are on the enemy's
ground
because when you came in there was this
huge triangular hall
everything was purple and there was a
pulpit
with a with a hanging in front of it
which says the age of aquarius
and then there were these loudspeakers
they're not loudspeakers microphones
that were hanging down and seating
around around this room
and then later when i spoke to the
channel
when my father in lord introduced me
he told me that they had
meetings there where they channeled the
information
and he would probably stand on that
pulpit
and then government officials and sports
officials
and he mentioned a whole lot of names
and i'm not going to go into the names i
i probably forgot most of them some of
them stick to my mind
and that they come to get information
and instructions as to how to proceed
and he also showed me letters written to
president of the united states and prime
ministers of england
showing them that showing me basically
that he was in contact with the
with the high officials and
letters that he'd received back stating
thank you for the information we'll
implement as soon as possible
and when we left that place my
father-in-law
was horrified
and he was he was saying that i was it
wasn't very nice of me to milk him not
knowing that i was not one of them
yes so you know these things are things
that i experienced personally
and at the later occasion when that
particular
channel had actually died
and i was back there because i was
trying to get hold of the blavatsky
books those people that were
know my testimony what
fascinated me in that particular
encounter was that
he said when when you get to blavatsky
then you have arrived
so this was the highest level that you
should be
interested in but also what fascinated
me
is his interaction according to his
own admission yeah with the theological
schools
and the training that some of these
theologians
get from these esoteric sources
which tells me that babylon has fallen
has fallen
has definitely fallen
so this is my personal experience people
will say i'm making it up
i always had witnesses with me but
these are just things that happened and
you know
there is a commandment which says thou
shalt not
bring false testimony so
i cannot deny my own my own experience
so i know that these connections do take
place
i saw it with my own eyes
but i was never involved fortunately
yeah
so yes these things are real
and then we spoke about in the last one
about
the strange prediction about this great
deep destruction and depopulation and
cities going and
it couldn't be migration because all of
them were going down it couldn't
they said it wasn't going to be war they
said it wasn't going to be
pestilence and some populations like
china and india didn't really move
neither russia
but when you look at the christian world
when you look at
germany when you look at england when
you look at the united states of america
even canada australia new zealand
they all receive massive knocks in their
population
which is astounding and their economies
yeah are just totally trashed according
to the predictions
now we're not going to go according to
those predictions
we have a different filter and that
filter is the bible
and so i think we should continue and
say
right now what what does our filter say
instead of saying what the conspiracists
are saying or what the predictions are
what does the filter say what does the
bible and the spirit of prophecy have to
say on the issue
and then we'll try and pull it together
yes so shall we move on with that
please we have
the admonition get out of the cities
and we've had it for a long time right
correct
and if i look at the
massive population reduction that some
of these people are predicting
uh and we we shifted to the time of
god's
justice and his
judgments then it wouldn't be
necessarily pandemic it wouldn't be this
that or the other it wouldn't even be
war it could be judgments now we have
had warnings
and if you go to the bible there have
also been warnings in the bible
get out of the cities jerusalem being
the one
that was used as an example get out
yeah because it is going to be destroyed
right
that's what the bible said so if you
make that application to the end of time
it becomes rather
important that we take heed of these
things there were also
a lot he was told not
to leave go to the cities in the first
place and then when he went to the
cities he was also admonished to get out
of the cities yes he had to get out and
it was very hard to get out yes
not so easy to get out
here's a statement from last day events
when iniquity abounds in the nation
there's always to be heard some voice
giving warning and instruction
as the voice of lot was heard in sodom
yet lot could have preserved his family
from many evils had he not
made his home in this wicked
polluted city all that lot and his
family did in sodom
could have been done by them even if
they had lived in a place some distance
away from the city
that's pretty good advice yep
now we've just had a rather devastating
week
in terms of what can happen in cities
and let's just look at what
this little video shows us
[Music]
what
foreign
now these horrendous events that took
place in
beirut they weren't directly because of
a judgment of god
this was human negligence
there were all kinds of reports of
course afterwards
some conspiratorial let's stick with the
with the status quo and the news media
this was a disaster waiting to happen
because of human negligence etc
but if you were not in the city then
this would not
have hit you now what if this starts
happening
on a large scale yes and what if the
judgments of god
are coming to this world because of the
iniquity
sometimes god does these things or
allows these things
so people can wake up right yep
beirut explosion rescue workers
frantically search for survivors as
lebanon capital confronts massive
devastation i mean these are terrible
disasters
and in the cities people are crowded
together
you are subject to all that happens in a
city
device crime
all of these as god's commandment
keeping people
we must leave the cities as did enoch we
must work in the cities but not
dwell in them now
if you work in the cities something
could happen to you
while you are working in the city well
god knows that
so let us just give people a little bit
of hope here
my friend always says man is immortal
until his work is done
and we know that god in his mercy will
put many to sleep
before the final events because people
just would not be able to handle it
so we have to be realistic things are
not going to be easy
yeah and we are admonished to work the
cities but not by dwelling in them
now if something should happen to you
while you are in those cities
god knows that and it's just a twinkling
of an eye
the promises that god has for his people
are just amazing and if we are of a
fearful disposition
then read the promises i have marked my
bible
with the letter p when there is a
promise
and if you start reading your bible and
you find something that is encouraging
put the letter p because god is not a
liar
and every single promise in the bible
is for his people now
god never promised that calamity will
never come to you
yeah but god promised that even
if calamity should come to you he's got
it under control he's still there
he's still pretty so we should if and if
it
is in his plan that you should not
survive
the calamity it will also be for the
best
then it will be seed so god is in
control
and we must trust god we must have the
attitude of job
even if he slay me
yet will i trust him
so the cities are to be worked from
outposts says the messenger of god
shall not the cities be worn yes
not by god's people living in them
but by their visiting them to warn them
of what is coming
upon the earth there is something coming
and when this thing starts happening
and by implication some of it will
certainly happen
before the close of probation because if
this
is supposed to be
an inducement to change
what's the point if probation is closed
right
i think to say
the bible calls the plagues after
the close of probation the seven last
plagues yes
so if it's last plagues there will be
plagues
before it and the bible says it's the
wrath of god
poured out without mixture in other
words there's no mercy involved anymore
some of these destructions are actually
mercy yes
some of our cities are now so wicked
and just the blatant apostasy and the
outright confrontational attitude
towards
god and cries out even human beings are
saying how long
lord are you going to tolerate this kind
of thing just shows how long suffering
god is
yes and when it does happen let's say
it does happen and a city is destroyed
let's say an entire city is destroyed
and millions of people lose their lives
well at the moment how many people died
in beirut
they say the death toll is now over 200
there are about 400 people at least
missing
so far and thousands have been injured
that's a
that's a pretty uh hectic event
yes but whatever whole city is destroyed
would people then start thinking they
might
for years i have been given special
light that we are not to center our work
in the cities
the turmoil and confusion that fill
these cities the conditions brought
about
by the labor unions and strikes would
prove a great hindrance to our work
well just go to the united states at the
moment and try
and preach yes in some of these cities
that
are full of riots well let's call it
then protesters
yes um these
so-called uh peaceful protests putting
churches
ablaze so i wondered like you said
if you go and try and evangelize now how
successful will you be
yes i was also thinking people that say
we should join the movement because of
the social
implications implications and so on have
they
thought about trying to go into the
protests and doing evangelism
yes i don't think it will be very
successful but nevertheless
be assured that the call is for our
people to locate
miles away from the large cities
now that explosion in by beirut was felt
miles away yes that's amazing yeah
i'm not saying you have to move 150
miles from this from
you i don't feel it but this is good
advice
be assured that the call is for our
people to locate
miles away from the large cities one
look at san francisco as it is today
would speak to your intelligent
minds showing you the necessity of
getting out
of the cities do not establish
institutions in the cities but seek a
rural location
the call is come out from among them and
be
ye separate the very atmosphere of the
city is polluted
let your schools be established away
from the cities where agricultural and
other industries can be carried on
it has ever been god's way
not to locate yes in the cities
nimrod kane was the first city builder
yes and enoch was put in charge his son
now this is the
not the good enoch this is enoch son of
kane
and the masonic order
traces their lineage back to that
particular enoch
i mean morals and dogma traces their
heritage back to enoch son of cain
this is just unbelievable yeah and
people
don't see it they think you know
who who is albert pike after all in the
masonic order
now when i was in the 33 degree temple
there allowed tourists in there and
i had a burning desire to see what was
going
on outside of the tourist district
so i developed a great need to go and
search
[Laughter]
and so we went down and
we came to an area where they had this
museum for albert pike
with all his stuff lying there his pipe
and his books and his library
and everything and
when we were walking somebody discovered
us
and shouted at us that we were standing
on
holy ground oh yeah and this is this
massive building in in washington where
all
the high politicians you know gather
around
and i said oh why is this holy ground
is there a washroom anywhere around here
and they said no it's albert pike's
remains that are there
so this is holy ground yeah this
uh channeler of luciferian doctrine
and you know people don't realize that
these things are real this is really
happening
yes and i don't know why god in his
mercy
allowed me to see some of these things
in my life maybe
so that i could you know
with some authority and not just
hearsay relate to some of these things
and show the world
that this world is steeped in wickedness
we have to separate from these things
didn't it give you a different view of
the
bible text that tells us that our fight
is not against flesh and blood
absolutely i think that's also one thing
that maybe helped you because
a lot of us that don't have
didn't have an encounter like this don't
quite realize it you know there's a big
war going on in the spiritual realm but
not
as and the deception i mean i had all
this demonic activity in my home and
i got the church involved and i got the
roman catholic church involved
and how it worked out that their
exorcist
sort of cleared up the issue but as soon
as i realized that even that was a
deception
they phoned me immediately and said your
father is having a problem in the other
side of the world
and in purgatory he's suffering because
of what you are doing now
studying the bible right wow and i said
excuse me how do you know
how do you know that my father
is suffering in purgatory who told you
and the exorcist told me it's the nuns
they are in communication with the
spirits and the spirits
told them about that time i knew there
was no purgatory the bible doesn't know
anything about a purgatory
and the dead sleep yes this is
uh luciferian doctrine that
the dead are active and alive as we
discussed in a previous one
so this great deception was the final
attempt to bring me back into line
and these things happened this is not
this is not something that happened in a
corner
this was real and how did this man
this exorcist that dealt with the
situation in my home how did he know
ahead of time what was going on in my
home yes
i mean just unbelievable so you know
people that
say that this is a conspiracy theory
when they grew up in cotton wool they
have no idea
this is real interesting that you
mentioned that that
this was the last form of satan
trying to get me back get you back
don't you think that this will also be
one of his last attempts brilliant
in the world absolutely he will manifest
his heathen power
right he will manifest himself he will
display himself and
people will fall for it if they do not
know their bible
say for instance you've been somebody
that didn't believe in these things
and a deceased one of your deceased
relatives appears to you
it's going to be hard not to believe
that that is a true
appearance absolutely you're going to
say whoa
what is going on here imagine a parent
and his child appears to him a deceased
child
i had so many weird experiences in my
life
i remember when my father died
i through circumstances
they were incredible was the only one at
his at his deathbed
and i i held a vigil at his deathbed
and it was it was
very peaceful just stopped breathing
and when he had stopped breathing
entirely
he sat up in bed and he stretched out
his arms like this
it was it had such a huge impression
upon me i mean i wasn't a believer yet
right yes
i was not a christian i was still an
atheist but i was a spiritist i was an
occultist yeah which is a misnomer right
actually yeah and
that look and then he fell down and he
was dead
right now when i drove home
i actually spoke to him as if he was
sitting in the car with me
and i got home and the weirdest things
happen
people will say you know maybe this man
has totally lost it
but uh did i really lose it when later
that exorcist in my home
was being thrown around like a rag doll
what threw him around well what picked
him up and threw him around
nothing no definitely
not nothing definitely not nothing so
i just want to tell the viewers this
stuff is real
there is a demonic world out there and
that demonic world has got humanity
to the ultimate stage of rebellion
our only safety is that thus says the
lord
you cannot believe the evidence of your
own eyes
you have to trust that the word is truth
and ignore the evidence of your own eyes
if your
great-grandfather should stand in front
of you looking exactly like you remember
him from your pick from the pictures
that you saw
that's no evidence because the bible
says the dead know nothing they will
have no part on this earth
they are asleep they are waiting for the
resurrection
amen now if you take this city san
francisco that
the spirit of prophecy warned against
it's in a pretty poor shape
right many things happened in san
francisco
it was destroyed by an earthquake yes
and people were admonished at that stage
to get
out of san francisco but many of them
moved back
many of them moved back it became the
epicenter of the hippie movement
which of course was also steered and
directed by the jesuits new age
the new age the age of aquarius that you
mentioned earlier
they said the the golden age the and the
age of aquarius
also that whole movement started in san
francisco
and also uh well alternative lifestyle
movement
all of these things emanate from san
francisco
it's like a modern-day sodom and
gomorrah
so what did donald trump say
about this particular city
over the holiday president trump put the
blame on the house speaker
and california's governor for not
cleaning up san francisco's homeless
problem
in one tweet he said nancy pelosi's
district in california has rapidly
become one of the worst anywhere in the
u.s
when it comes to the homeless and crime
it has gotten so bad so fast
she has lost total control and along
with her equally incompetent governor
gavin newsom
it is a very sad site he also tweeted
that if the governor can't fix the
problem
the federal government will get involved
san francisco supervisor matt haney says
the problem is getting worse the latest
homeless count in san francisco showed a
big
increase in the last two years to more
than 9 000 people
so once the city goes down
morally it goes down in its
infrastructure
and all of those things
here's an article which says why san
francisco's homeless population keeps
increasing
more than 25 000 people were counted as
homeless during an overnight tally
conducted in san francisco
that's incredible yeah that's a lot of
people
and and this is a this is a first world
country
now this is of course nothing when you
compare it with a third world country
if you go to india and or our own
country
our own country it is terribly terribly
sad
and people are suffering and one wonders
how long
god is going to look upon humanity
in its state the lord calls for his
people to locate away from the cities
for in such an
hour as you think not
fire and brimstone will be reigned from
heaven upon these
cities proportionate to their sins will
be their visitation
when one city is destroyed let not our
people regard this matter as a light
affair
and think that they may a favorable
opportunity
offers build themselves homes in that
same
destroyed city that's an interesting
statement
yes so here we we hear
that cities will be destroyed by fire
and brimstone by fire and brimstone now
how is san francisco destroyed
by an earthquake by an earthquake now if
one city is destroyed don't go and build
there again did god's people go and
build there again
yes yes many of them did
in other words if this city was
once already subject to judgment
could it be subject to judgment again
yes
is it possible that god will rain down
fire and brimstone
and destroy cities even before the close
of probation
yeah so that it could act as a seed
could that put a knock into a population
and make them think
i think it can and then it's also
admonished not to go and build in that
city again don't go back when they
rebuild it
that all who would understand the
meaning of these things
read the 11th chapter of revelation
so now we are linking the destruction of
cities
to the book of revelation yes read
every verse and learn the
things that are yet to take place in the
cities
read also the scenes portrayed in the
18th chapter of the same book
so we have marching orders yes
our marching orders are when we see the
things that are happening in the world
today
and when we see the signs of these
destructive elements taking over
then read the 11th chapter of revelation
so i think we must do that yes we must
also read
the scenes portrayed in the 18th chapter
of the same book
so we have to do a bible study so the
one is a type historically
and the other one is the anti-type right
yep
let's look at it but before we go there
here's an interesting very interesting
quote in the great controversy
for seven years a man continued to go
up and down the streets of jerusalem
declaring the woes that were to come
upon the city
by day and by night he chanted the wild
dirt
a voice from the east the voice from the
west the voice from the four winds
a voice against jerusalem and the temple
a voice against the bridegroom
and the bride and a voice against all
the people
this strange being was imprisoned and
scourged
they beat him yeah but now a complaint
escaped his lips
to insult an abuse he only answered
woe to jerusalem woe woe
to the inhabitants thereof his warning
christ
ceased not until he was slain in the
siege
he had foretold for seven years
this man was walking around
and warning the city but is it possible
that somebody could be doing this
in the times that we are living in let's
have a look
woe to you america for the hour of your
judgment has come
the first woe has passed behold the
second world
your city streets shall be turned to
stubble
and your skies shall be filled with
smoke
fire will fall from heaven and then you
will know
that i am the lord your god repent
united states of america
for the kingdom of god has come near to
you
[Music]
you should repent in dust and ashes and
return to the lord
and he will have mercy judgment
is all around you there is a storm over
our lands
i find that very interesting
here is a man who claims that three and
a half years ago the lord
instructed him to start warning the
nation and this is what he does
so three and a half years have passed
well that would mean if the other one
preached for seven years that would be
another three and a half years let's not
go there we'll get into trouble
yeah mathematics is always problematic
we're not saying that this is the end
i'm just saying there are some
interesting parallels there's some
interesting things
happening but it's
you can't um get away from telling
or saying it's interesting yes it's
it's interesting let's read a little bit
more
this comes from the review and herald
jerusalem was
lost because of its obstinate refusal to
acknowledge the truth
this the world is doing today
men refuse to see the truth that is
plainly revealed in the word of god this
is the standard right
the word of god a thus says the lord
is regarded as of no account
while the words of men are given great
authority
and as the inhabitants of jerusalem were
punished
so will those be punished who refuse to
receive
truth god would have us realize
that by the city of jerusalem a world
is represented christ's utterances
regarding the destruction of jerusalem
are ever to be connected with the more
terrible destruction of the world
now we know that the world will be
destruct destroyed
right at the end by the by the plagues
and particularly the last plague when
the great hail will come and the great
earthquake
but the judgments of god will be in the
land before then
and then it's not a time to be in the
cities right correct
as the the spirit of god withdraws
itself
and the four angels start loosening the
wind
so let me just go back to deagle.com
when they said all these places
and they mentioned particularly the
christian world if we analyze it like
that they don't say that we are saying
that just by
looking at the numbers will be the ones
that are hardest hit that's possible
but they shouldn't like esau rejoice
that the great adversaries over there in
the west
have been destroyed because their
calamity is also coming
it is wishful thinking on their part to
think
that they will be unaffected because
the prophecy in daniel tells us
that when the rock strikes this
political system on this planet how much
is going to be left
nothing nothing there will be dust and
what will happen to the dust
even that will be swept away nothing is
going to remain the whole world is going
to be destroyed
the point of all of this is
don't make light of this no don't say to
people
the time is not yet she clearly said
that the time is already there we should
have heeded this long ago
we should never have gone back and built
places in cities that god had already
once destroyed like in the case
of of san francisco
so the very last city that you want to
be in is
particularly one that has already once
before
received judgment and certainly didn't
repent
just by their action their fruits
their fruits how did the
the whole drug world come into the world
didn't it start off in san francisco
and today as we see it is not much
better
here is another statement jesus did not
answer his disciples by taking up
separately the destruction of jerusalem
and the last great day of his coming the
city of jerusalem
represented the world and the utterances
regarding its destruction
are to be connected with the world's
more
terrible destruction
that's horrendous yes if you think about
jerusalem
the people were starving yes they were
eating their own children
now people will say we're fear-mongering
no we're not
yeah we are giving a warning correct
and this is a warning that god himself
also gave his disciples when you see
that this city is encompassed by armies
and they're setting up their false
standard of righteousness
get out get out that city is going to be
destroyed
they ate their own children and when it
was finally destroyed
for miles there were crucifixes as the
people were
slaughtered and it says here
that the destructions are to be
connected with the world's
more terrible destruction
and speaking of jerusalem his prophetic
words reach beyond that event to the
conflagration
that will take place in that day when
the lord
shall rise out of his place to punish
the inhabitants of the earth for their
iniquity who's going to punish
god could fire come from heaven yes
even that town cryo or country crier
said that fire was going to come down
from heaven yes
and the spirit of prophecy said the same
thing
the description of the two events is
mingled and the entire subject is a
warning to those
who shall live in the last sins of
earth's history
so it's not crying fear-mongering no
it's a warning that should be given that
should be given
and if we are faithful sentinels then we
must bring this
warning get out so we've been admonished
to study the book of revelation and
particularly chapter 11.
can i before we go into chapter 11 can i
maybe ask
now that we've talked about getting out
of the cities
is there maybe just some short practical
um advice advice
that you can give to people that are
currently in the cities and would
maybe like to get out well it's always
as the lord
opens the way you know isaiah says
my people shall not leave in haste
of course if you're terry and terry and
terry you might have to leave in haste
a lot certainly left in haste
so what are what are the procedures
well let no man tell you your duty and
no man can tell you where to go
or what to do you have to be
on your knees and you have to ask god
to open the way and you must claim the
promises
but you can't just wait for it to fall
from heaven
you have to set certain things in motion
you must put your feet
in the jordan you must put your feet in
the jordan so if you are living in the
city
my advice would be get rid of your
assets in the city
and locate away from the city if that is
at all possible
of course if you're not able to do that
then god will take care of that too
then you trust in the lord and the lord
will take care of it even if you should
be sleeping that would be
also in his hands it's only for a moment
so the big issue is trust yes
faith claim the promises
and if god opens the wa the door
then walk through it thank you
so let's have a look at revelation
chapter 11.
and there was given me a read like unto
a rod
and the angel stood saying rise
and measure the temple of god
now let's just stop there we're going to
go through this
how are we told to go through it
thoroughly every
verse every verse
now the bible clearly tells us paul
tells us
that the church is the temple of god ye
are the temple
of the living god and
there's going to be a measuring rod
to measure the temple and the altar
and them that worship therein
so the church is the temple of god
the altar is in terms of what they
believe
in terms of the the sacrifice that was
made for their sins
how do they relate to it right
and the people that are in the church so
it is a
thorough measuring of the entire system
structure the belief system
and the individual it's going to be
measured
do you measure up
measure up with what well with the word
of god right
so it starts off the very first verse
tells us that judgment
begins with the house of course of god
they're going to be tested
so they're going to look at the church
going to look at the belief system
and going to look at every single
individual
claiming to be within that structure and
belief system
now do we have
many indications today
has in the case in the time of a literal
jerusalem
that all is not well in the house of god
yes do we have many voices
which go counter or contrary to
the word of god and the spirit of
prophecy yes
is that a reason to say that the entire
church
is in apostasy no no
because why would god measure it then to
see what is left of the temple
what is actually in harmony with the
worship system
and who is still in harmony with it
there's going to be a measuring
yes correct um this
lots of people that
judge a church by its members you cannot
no you if the
standard is you see what they
structure doctrine and um what they
teach
yeah and if the people inside of the
church don't follow that
it doesn't mean the church is a problem
i always i always have this idea in my
mind
about how god works and i know i've told
the story in my
in my testimonies many times
but one that that really stood out for
me
was in a uh
for a previous com communist bloc
country i was doing an evangelistic
campaign and the pastor that was
assigned
to take part in this evangelistic
campaign was a young man
and he was extreme
liberal absolutely
well 190 degrees the opposite
of anything that i for example stood for
and he was not interested at all
he was just way out there
and he was only interested in music and
singing and being happy and
all of these messages about end time
and this was to him just such a terrible
waste of time
and he used to come with his guitar
hanging around his neck
and he would try and postpone the
inevitable lecture for as long
as possible and he his whole
expression just told me that he was
not on this wavelength it was really
hard to do the campaign
under those circumstances yes but i did
it and i went through the entire thing
and he was in absolute opposition
and then right at the end
suddenly his whole deportment changed
everything changed and he became
so serious and he came to me and he said
to me
i have been hit like with a
lightning bolt
and i was totally surprised i thought
he'd listen to what i said he never
listened to a word
i said i irritated him right he didn't
like this message
at all and i said what happened he said
my grandmother
had a chat with me and my grandmother
said
to me the other evening now i can die
in peace because i know that the old
advent message is still alive
and being preached in the world today
and
that struck him not what i said
what his grandmother said to him that
hit him between the eyes
so you know i don't know who's going to
wake up i cannot judge
if i had to judge all of these people i
would judge them by
my standard thank god it is god
who has the measuring rod
but if you are willfully
disobedient or even willfully ignorant
yeah you come into this judgment if the
teachings
of your church body is contrary to
god's word then it doesn't then you have
to get out
of that church body correct then you
have to come out of a yes it doesn't
matter if your local pastor
is not preaching the same as a church
body
yeah that church still falls under that
church body
so that you have to you're right people
say you know
i know that my church officially teaches
this that and the other let's say
predestination
and i know it's not biblical but my
local pastor doesn't worry about that so
i'm
no if the body is wrong then you have to
leave that body yes
but if that body has biblical
doctrines and they don't adhere to them
as individuals that's god's problem yes
yeah
okay let's continue with revelation
chapter 11.
so verse one tells us that god is going
to
apply a standard of measure
but the court which is without the
temple
leave out and measure it not for it is
given unto the gentiles and the holy
city
shall they tread under their foot forty
and two months
so the other court stands for the
gentile nations
outside and they're going to trample
the city which is basically the truth
for 42 months now this
number 42 months is exactly the same as
the 1260 days or the three and a half
prophetic years
and parallelism will tell you this for
example
it will say in revelation chapter 12 for
it will talk about the church the
wilderness
and the time frame 1260
days and then in a parallel text it will
say the church
the wilderness 42 months yes
so you know that they are the same time
times and half a time time
times and half the time the hebrew year
had 360 days
so three and a half times 360 is 1260.
it will tell you 1260 days which is
exactly the same time period the hebrew
month
had 30 days 42 times 30 1260.
so this is referring to the time
when the heathen nations the gentiles
would trample the truth for 42 months
a reference to the period of papal
dominance
from 538 a.d to 1798
when god would permit
an apostate counter system to be erected
that for example violates the doctrine
of the altar
that's important yes because the altar
stands
for the sacrificial lamb that died for
the sins of the world
rome as we saw taught that your works
will be the means to your salvation
rome taught that or still teaches
that you pay the price for your sins
even after death in a place called
purgatory so they totally
destroy the message of salvation
through faith alone they call it an
anathema
so for 42 prophetic months for 1
260 days a day for a year
1 260 years
this system would attack
the church the doctrine of the church
and individuals within the church
and i will give power unto my two
witnesses
and they shall prophesy a thousand
two hundred and three score days can you
see there the parallelism 42 months
here it is given as 1260 days
same time period and they will be
clothed
in sackcloth now we need to know who the
two witnesses are
they cannot be too individual literal
people
why not because this is a prophetic time
period
and they're not going to prophesy as
literal people for 1260 years
yes so the bible has to tell us who the
two witnesses
are and then it tells us who they are
they are the two olive trees
and the two candlesticks standing before
the god
of the earth now a candlestick gives
light
thy word is a lamp
unto my feet and to my
path so we're dealing with the word of
god
they are going to prophesy
in other words preach the truth but
in sackcloth they will be suppressed
they will be downtrodden they will be
preaching against all odds
and if any man will hurt them fire
proceeds out of their mouth and devours
their enemies
and if any man will hurt them he must in
this manner be
killed don't mess with god's word
now we had a whole what's up
about messing with god's word right two
of them
so this same power that trod
on the city the same power
is one that messes with the word of god
and they will be burnt
because fire proceeds out of their mouth
they will be destroyed by fire it's
interesting
if we go to the bible stories and
punishments
prostitutes were punished by stoning
yeah whereas
in this particular case if it was a
priest's
daughter that prostituted herself then
she was burnt with fire
so this is a priestly system
that will be destroyed by fire
and it is the word of god that condemns
you
let's just go to a parallel text in the
book of zechariah
chapter 4 verse 3 where we have this
reference to the two olive trees
which we just read in revelation 11.
one upon the right side of the bowl and
the other on the left side thereof so i
answered and spoke to the angel that
talked to me saying
what are these my lord and the angel
that talked with me answered and said
unto me
knowest thou not what these be and i
said no my lord.
then he answered and spake unto me this
is the word of the lord.
so there's the answer there's the answer
so there's your parallel text
and unto zerubbabel saying not by might
nor by power but by my spirit says the
lord of hosts and this is
this is our weapon
like martin luther said let the minds
clash
but keep the fists down okay
our weapon is the word of god thus says
the lord
now in revelation chapter 11 for 1260
years
god's word was suppressed yes if you
read the bible
in your own tongue rome put you to death
yes
there's no doubt that they did that
chapter 4 verse 11 says then answer thy
and said
unto him what are these two olive trees
upon the right side of the candlestick
and upon the left side thereof didn't we
just read that also in the book of
revelation
yes yes and i answered again and i said
unto him
what be these two olive branches which
through the golden pipes empty the
golden
oil out of themselves
and he answered me and says knows thou
not what is being i said no my lord
and he said these are the two anointed
ones
that stand by the lord of the whole
earth
it's a very similar language yes by the
way perhaps you can put a link in
to the zechariah series which we
also did yeah yeah
all right now the oil stands for the
holy spirit so this is
the holy spirit feeding
the power into the word and giving it
to the world and the two anointed ones
we have two then we had two
in the book of revelation chapter 11.
so what do they stand for they stand for
the old and the new testament because
it's the word of god
yes now what's the difference between
the old testament and the new testament
the old testament is the word of god in
type
and the new testament is the word of god
in antitype
the one is the fulfillment of the other
the two augment each other yes the one
doesn't replace the other
no never does it replace it
it fulfills it yes explains it
expounds it and you cannot be
without one or the other you need them
both
very very important because like you
know a lot of people say no
the old testament was let's cut it off
right we don't need it
jesus did take jesus took away the old
testament
yeah and we spoke about emmaus
what book did jesus use to explain
everything about himself the bible study
was done out of the old testament
absolutely i mean in corinthians paul
says
everything there in the desert and
was for our admonition that's it
absolutely so now that we've established
that this is the word of god
and that it was prophesying in sackcloth
in other words it was
suppressed downtrodden
we go to verse six these the old and the
new testament the witness thereof
have power to shut heaven that it rain
not in the days of their prophecy
and have power over waters to turn them
to blood
and to smite the earth with all plagues
as often as they will
well if god says it's not going to rain
it's not going to rain
yes and this is of course a reference to
the elijah message where elijah
said that it's not going to rain for
three and a half years
that is a type of this spiritual drought
that we are having here portrayed in the
book of revelation
chapter 11. so there
were in an anti-typical sense
prophecies that said that it would not
reign
in other words there will be no
outpouring
of the spirit of the spirit in a great
measure
and they have power over the waters to
turn them to blood
if god says there will be retributive
action
by his word then it will happen
and to smite the earth with all plagues
as often
as they will so there will be judgments
of god
in the land and in the world
because of the willful neglect of god's
word
do we see willful neglect of god's word
in the world
what is taught at schools creation or
evolution evolution
and the way that people talk about god
these days
is absolutely horrendous is satan
worship blatant satan worship
setting up statues of bafflement in the
world's capitals is this
something that's happening in the world
yes absolutely
just as verily as it explains here that
the world will be
destitute of the word of god so we can
see it but the judgments are coming
and when they have finished their
testimony and that's in other words
after the three and a half years
the beast that ascendeth out of the
bottomless pit shall make war against
them
and shall overcome them and kill them
this is an astounding prophecy
so for three and a half years during the
dark ages
they testified
people were slaughtered they were put in
on the rack
they were tortured to death burnt at the
stake
because they believed in this word of
god
and after that time so around about the
period
1798 the beast
that ascendeth out of the bottomless pit
now beast according to
prophecy is a political system
it's a political system it's a political
entity
so there will be a political entity that
comes out of the bottomless pit it's
definitely not from god
yeah it's from the other side
and we'll make war against them and make
war against god's word
the people shall overcome them and kill
them
so now here in the book of revelation we
have
the possibility that this is a literal
prophecy
with a greater application to a
universal
state of mind now what happened
after that 1260 year prophecy what
happened
round about 1798
well france
actually revolted against
everything religious
and they literally banned the bible
we will deal with that in a moment yeah
and the philosophy
that came out of what was called the
french revolution
became the philosophy of the world yes
and france exported that philosophy
to the united states it's interesting
that the founding fathers
called themselves by the name of
these french revolution heroes they
called themselves rob spierer
they called themselves voltaire and they
communicated with each others in their
letters in this way and this whole
idea of this liberty this freedom
was transported this whole ideology
out of the bottomless pit was
transported
to the world via the united states of
america
and it is france that sent the stature
of liberty
which is mitra has the crown of mitra
around its head
and the torch of lucifer in the hand
and they call it liberty yes
now this is interesting now it gets even
more fascinating
and their dead bodies shall lie in the
street of the great
city now when the bible talks about the
great city
it's a reference to babylon right yes
correct it's a reference to babylon so
here
in anti-typical babylon
which is in terms of the philosophy of
the french revolution
which is anti-god based on reason as we
will see
and then it tells us this interesting
version which is
spiritually called sodom
and egypt now
let's not get too imp politically
incorrect
but everybody that has a thinking cop
cap on will realize what sodom
and egypt stands for sodom stands for
licentiousness in all its forms
uh has the west inherited that yes
absolutely right but it's also called
egypt
spiritually egypt where our lord was
crucified now was jesus crucified in
egypt no
was he crucified in sodom no he
verily was spiritually crucified
they nailed him as verily to the cross
as though they had literally done it by
rejecting the plan of salvation
now we were talking about the king of
the north and the king of the south
yes and it says here
that this philosophy
is spiritually called egypt
so this is king of the south philosophy
yes
and this is a philosophy that must be
overthrown at the end of time by king of
the north
philosophy this is interesting
now the papacy is the king of the north
and this one over here has to be
overthrown
but we read that the two sit at the same
table
they're actually buddies
where our lord was crucified because
both of these systems the one
that for one thousand two hundred and
sixty years king of the north philosophy
had
persecuted god's people yes
was replaced by one that is spiritually
king of the south
which says get god out of our lives
let's crucify this
religious nonsense
that the two sit at the same table and
that the king of the north philosophy
will come again
which again crucifies god's people yes
interesting very interesting
and they of the people and the kindreds
and tongues and nations shall
see their dead bodies three days and a
half
and there you have it in days again
right
yes so this is again a reference to the
elijah message it's a reference to
the 1260 day prophecy
and here it says they lay there three
days and a half
and shall not suffer their dead bodies
to put in graves
so what happened here during this rise
of this philosophical political
system which the bible calls
a system ascending out of the bottomless
pit
well let's leave it there we'll come
back to those verses let's go
and look at the great controversy
the great city in whose streets the
witnesses are slain
and where their dead bodies lie is
spiritually egypt
of all nations presented in bible
history
egypt most boldly denied the existence
of the living god
and resisted his commands
no monarch ever ventured upon more
open and high-handed rebellion against
the authority of heaven
than did the king of egypt that is king
of the south philosophy we said that we
would clarify clarify
who is the king of the south now
remember
he wasn't a religious he had many gods
as we discussed
so don't look for a totally a religious
system
but it is a system that defies the god
of heaven
blatantly the other one also defies
him but deceptively yes
it looks like he is he is serving god
he is correct he's finding ways
that seem to be serving him while
negating him
so both of them are against god
when the message was brought him by
moses in the name of the lord pharaoh
proudly answers who is jehovah that i
should obey his voice to let israel
israel go i know not jehovah neither
will i let israel go
then she says quite plainly in the great
controversy this is atheism
and the nation represented by egypt
would give voice
to a similar denial of the claims of the
living god
and would manifest a like spirit of
unbelief and defiance do we see that
spirit in the world today
at every level the great city is
also compared spiritually to sodom
the corruption of sodom and breaking the
law of god was especially manifested in
licentiousness this is logical
to negate this would be to throw out
all logic out of the window
and this sin was also to be a preeminent
characteristic of the
nation that should fulfill the
specification of the scripture
now here again let's just make this
quite clear
she also said that the destructions of
the
setis at the end of time applies to
revelation chapter 11.
so this cannot be just one little nation
in isolation
this is a philosophy that arose
in one nation and was disseminated
across the entire globe
and when this philosophy becomes the
norm
judgments will come yes fire will come
down from heaven
and this philosophy and this
licentiousness
and this way of thinking will
be addressed by god himself yes
as a consequence what is going to happen
the world is going to witness it
and the world will be moved in the
direction of whose philosophy
king of the north yes which is also a
deception
yes so think about it logically
what is the end result total destruction
yeah so both systems are wrong yes but
the world
seeing the judgments of god
holds cities perhaps just disappearing
will say we have to get away from this
we have to get back to the witnesses
but the witnesses as interpreted by the
king of the north
and they fall into a second trap which
is worse than the first
western the first this is horrendous
so it will be like
let's drain the swamp and get rid of all
this secularism and all this
filthiness to join this
religious ins uh
gathering or institution or whatever you
can call it but this is
king of this babylonian conglomerate of
all the religions together
look so good looks so christian but this
is king of the north
oh terrible let's read some more
at the same time anarchy is seeking to
sweep away
all law do we see that
not only the mind but human the
centralizing of wealth and power
is that a problem today definitely the
vast combination for the enriching of
the
few at the expense of the many is that a
problem
yes the combination of the poorer
classes for the defense of their
interests and claims
do we have a spirit of unrest
the riot and bloodshed do we have that
the worldwide and this is the crux of
the matter
dissemination of the same teachings that
led to the french revolution all
are tending to involve the whole world
in a struggle
similar to that which convulsed france
so where this literal event took place
in the french revolution in france
that philosophy transported to the world
via the united states of america
which has this gift from france
the statue of liberty is going to lead
to
a worldwide struggle similar to that
which convulsed frauds
such are the influences to be made by
the youth today to stand amid
such upheavals they are now to lay the
foundations of character it's
very hard to do get out of the cities
in every generation and in every land
the true foundation and pattern for
character
building have been the same it's the
divine law
thou shalt love the lord thy god with
all thy heart and thy neighbor as
thyself the great principle made
manifest in the character and life of
our savior
is the only secure foundation and the
only guide
where our lord was crucified
that's a quote from revelation chapter
11.
this specification of the prophecy was
also fulfilled in france
in no land that the spirit of enmity
against christ
being more strikingly displayed in no
country had the truth encountered more
better and cruel opposition in the
persecution which france had visited
upon the confessors of the gospel
she had crucified christ in the person
of his disciples
who was behind the french revolution the
jesuits
you find them everywhere i once gave a
lecture called revolution tyrants
and wars yes and if you read the history
books
how many nations have been appalled
at this revolutionary philosophy
of the jesuits and they've been banned
in so many countries
and even you know the founding fathers
the faithful ones warned against
jesuitism
but it crept in this philosophy
in spite of it so let's get back
to the book of revelation chapter
11 because this is what we are dealing
with
right now so france actually
banned the bible and if we apply that to
the end of time
the bible will be as
verily banned from society as it was
then
yes it's not allowed to be in the
schools we're not allowed to teach this
and we're not allowed to use the name of
jesus you're not allowed to pray
i mean it's everywhere right
and they that dwell upon the earth shall
rejoice over them and make
merry and shall send gifts one to
the other because these two prophets
tormented them that dwelt on the earth
there will
be a rebellion against god's word
and they will make merry they will get
drunk they will
mock god's word publicly yes
will we see that in our time i think we
will see it in a moment right
they will mock god's word
and after three days and a half the
spirit of life from god
entered into them and they stood upon
their feet and great
fear fell upon them which saw them
so god will revive the testimony
in the end and there will be a
message of warning to the world
god will give life to the word
so somebody has to start preaching the
word again yes
and the warning of elijah
so the elijah message must go to the
world and the elijah
message is the three angels messages
has to go to the world so god will have
a body
that preaches the truth and
most people will array themselves
against it verse 7
and when they shall have finished their
testimony
the beast that ascendeth out of the
bottomless pit
a literal nation but also
a philosophy that will permeate
the other nations particularly the
united states and from there
into the world and particularly the
christian world
and they'll make war against them and
shall overcome them and kill them
now this is a picture of
the phrygian cap that was worn
in the french revolution this
is a symbol of freemasonry
this is a symbol of luciferian
worship we're going to show a little
video
that shows that the exact same
thinking that was present in the french
revolution is in the world today
even to the point of the guillotine
so let's have a look at this this is
fascinating
meanwhile protesters in washington d.c
setting up what appears to be
a guillotine outside the home of amazon
ceo jeff bezos
show casone with the details now cheryl
maria of course the guillotine famously
used for
beheadings during the french revolution
it was first spotted outside of the
billionaire's home
on sunday demonstrators also put up
posters in front of his home that read
quote defund jeff bezos and quote
support our poor communities not wealthy
men
organizers say amazon works directly
with the police to surveil
us and they've doubled down on their
union busting they go on to say they
want to abolish
amazon it's unclear if bezos was home at
the time he has several homes we should
add
they're actually doing exactly
what the spirit of prophecy said the
same teaching the same reaction
down to the guillotine here is a puerto
rican
protest where they carried
a huge guillotine down the streets so
are we seeing
a worldwide dissemination of the same
teachings that led to the french
revolution
there was an article in the previous
whatsapp profit we
had where bernie sanders staffer
said guillotine the rich guillotine the
rich
so we want to get rid of the economic
order as it exists today
and replace it with something else so
some have called for the governor's
resignation
and protesters marched the guillotine to
the residence
where vacuuez lives
let's get back to revelation chapter 11
verse
9 and they of the people and the
kindreds and the tongues and the nations
are we on a universal scale here yes
shall see their dead bodies three days
and a half and shall not suffer their
dead bodies to be put
in graves in other words you can't
really kill god's word you can try
so from november 10 1793
to june 1797 which was
three and a half years france actually
banned the scriptures
and if we take that philosophy of
getting rid of the scriptures
to let's say the united states of
america
they as verily banned it by getting rid
of it out of schools
not being able to quote it etc
etc and this philosophy then spread to
all the other countries
yeah so if you go to
countries that are so-called christian
countries whether
you're talking about australia whether
you're talking about new zealand
whether you're talking about south
africa i mean you weren't even allowed
to use the name jesus anymore
and this was also the case in the united
states
and let's not even talk about the united
kingdom and all of these
places the philosophy of the french
revolution
king of the south philosophy
has ruled the whole the world yeah
and what will happen to it it will be
destroyed by the king of the north the
king of the north will overcome it
he will overcome it and then
they will resurrect these two witnesses
and say we have to get back to the word
of god but as we said before
they were packages in king of the north
philosophies
what a terrible deception and they that
dwell on the earth shall rejoice over
them and make
merry and shall accept gifts one to
another because these two prophets
tormented them that dwelt on the earth
and after three days and a half the
spirit of god entered
into them and they stood upon their feet
and great fear fell
upon them which saw them there will be a
three angels message
that goes out yes and it will be ignored
by the majority of humanity
but those that fear god will take heed
so in the literal french revolution
the entire structure was swept away
the entire political system was changed
we went from a system where the church
ruled the government to a totally
secular system
and then it'll be reversed
at the end of time when the king of the
north takes back
his power and the whole world wanders
after him
now what did they do in the french
revolution
here is a depiction of
the goddess of reason
this is interesting they took a
prostitute off the street
dressed her up like a goddess with a
solar blaze behind her and
marched her to the cathedral of notre
dame
very interesting yes and there they
enthroned her in the place of god
as the goddess of reason
interesting and then they bowed down and
worshiped her
now we've discussed that before who says
that the world should be governed by
reason
the jesuits yes and they made themselves
god
now if you take the philosophy of the
jesuits let's just take descartes
descartes was a jesuit voltaire who was
a jesuit these people were all
jesuits descartes said i think therefore
i
am and i once gave a sermon
and i titled it i think therefore he is
yes because they are saying
that their reason and their intelligence
is going to set the standard for what is
right and wrong they don't need god
but the fact that i can think implies
that there is a god who gave me the
capacity to think
so i must be subject to god so i prefer
saying i i think therefore therefore
he is anyway this goddess of reason
is also enshrined on the georgia guide
stones that we spoke about
so the worldwide dissemination of reason
is going to take the place
here's an interesting article from the
present truth volume 11 page 136 by
wagner and it says had the church of
rome repented of these things
had she ever disowned her inquisition
no in 1882 the dominican
monsavre openly defended the inquisition
in the pulpit of notre dame
how many millions of martyrs have been
put to death in the name of christianity
by that most unchristian and
anti-christian power the papacy will
never be known until the dead small and
great stand before god
now what happened to notre dame recently
since then it's been a symbol of hope
for paris an
emblem of transcendence if you will this
was also the home
of torturers during the inquisition
it has been a base for pilgrims for
centuries
it's been a temple of reason it's also
been believe it or not a shelter for
magicians who used to go there and hide
out
it was also a gathering place for the
surrealist movement here
it's also the church of emperors it was
there in december 2nd in 1804 when
napoleon bonaparte
crowned himself the emperor of france
it hasn't been restored since 1830
which was a project overseen by none
other than victor hugo the author
of the hunchback of notre dame uh it
became a centerpiece of paris in the
late 19th century
when hausmann the architect who rebuilt
the city
made notre dame cathedral what we call
here kilometers zero
the very center all roads leading to
paris
culminate at notre dame and it's now
burning down
i cannot help
but think that god
is sending a message to humanity
and what is humanity's response
restore it restore it send millions send
up put up a fund to restore and who are
the ones
who are giving the money isn't it all
the mega rich people in the world
some individuals in certain church
institutions also send money
they also send money well you know
i think there are better things to spend
your money on
than glorifying an institution of
torture and defiance towards god but it
is to me
interesting that humanity is more
concerned with
restoring that the image of defiance
towards god
than to listening to what god has to say
yes
well they can restore it and they can
put all their money in it
and individuals can send money to it
only in the end to have god destroy it
again in a final destruction that will
be
forever now the
philosophical implications are of course
enormous
so under this thinking the old and the
new testament
the two witnesses were obliterated
and we have the system that we have in
the world today
and because the system eventually leads
to anarchy and pain
and to the judgments of god
there will be a swing as we said
back to where we are with the king of
the north
correct protesters burn bible
american flag as tensions rise
in portland are we seeing the same thing
they did it in the french revolution and
now they're doing the same thing
and of course reasoning people look at
this and say what are they doing to the
two witnesses
here is uh the french revolution and out
of the french revolution
came of course the declaration of human
rights
with philosophers jesuit philosophers by
the way
i cannot emphasize this enough this must
be the most
horrendous organization that has
ever been allowed to flourish on this
planet
i mean i'm not the only one saying that
presidents of the united states have
said that
and if i look at their philosophies and
we've discussed this
nothing has changed they are so
blatantly in defiance to god
that it is just astounding and it's such
a deception because they
they portray themselves to be such
decent holy men yes they call themselves
the society of jesus
now it's astonishing to me that the
french revolution
brought this declaration of human rights
out
in the form of two tables of stone
with of course the fascii in between the
bundles of
rods tied together in unison
to rome now i'm not going to give
lectures on that right now but the the
sheer
arrogance is just astounding
and then of course it's all under the
the all-seeing eye which is one of the
symbols of the jesuit order
and they replace the law of god and the
word of god
with human rights they also
this is a lot of these symbols that you
mentioned
now they're also linked now a new
all-world order
but interesting how they start linking
it to
well weakening to the king of the south
philosophy yes
absolutely every single one of these
is against god's word and then
unfortunately the
majority of people expect this
savior or saving institution
institution will be christian but it
will be king of the north
absolutely now the papers here is of
course touted
human rights as an absolute must for all
humanity
i i once gave a lecture called they've
made void thy law
where i actually discuss human rights
and show that every single
one of prominence there are many things
which
which seem to the eye as you know
pretty good but every single one of them
is actually against god
yeah against the team it's against the
ten commandments it's a total reversal
of the ten commandments
and the devil has always been the master
of reversal
and how he always succeeds in presenting
something in such a
such a acceptable fashion when it is
actually totally contrary to the word of
god perhaps you can put that link in
there
thy law so descartes philosophy this
jesuit philosophy was then brought into
the
age of reason as written by thomas paine
one of the let's call him philosophers
of the united states
one of the most wicked occult people
that has ever
disgraced this earth and
i mean those are pretty harsh words but
uh
that is just a fact the philosophy
of this man this straight luciferian
philosophy
has done its work permeating the culture
and bringing this philosophy
into the world there's also a link that
i'll put into a
documentary on the
faith of the founding fathers
now remember that verse where it says
they will make merry
and they will be in open defiance
against god
do we see that in the world today do we
see this in the united states of america
exactly now how far does this defiance
go
well here's a video of a stadium in the
united states where over a thousand
musicians and ten thousand people at
least
went totally contrary to
everything that the bible stands for and
they sang highway to hell by
ac dc the name itself of course means
sexual adaptability
[Applause]
look at me
i don't think we need to play more i
think we can stop this i think we get
the picture
right is there open defiance against
god and against his word
yes absolutely
you know a band like ac dc
that can write such blatant
anti-god lyrics and music
that that should be incorporated by
other organizations
and that their music should be given to
little
children so that they become initiated
into this is this kind of rebellion that
we were talking about
and parents don't always realize this
yes because where's the most potent
place where satan can
the little mind and where does he eat
the little minds
with their own animation movies
correct because most of the times
parents don't even watch the movies with
the
children let's look at this one where
they actually used
the music of acdc
to feed it to little children
it's an actual fire oh yeah it happens
all the time you guys only hear about
the big ones
now i cut that a lot
because the whole song the complete song
plays in that movie
unbelievable unbelievable so the
defiance
is complete and the judgments of god
are coming into the world we have
statements in the spirit of prophecy
that
thousands of cities are going to be
destroyed
it is imperative that god's people
should heed the warning
and when god opens the way that they
should come out of the cities
because even according to their own time
frames
these things are just before us
personally i don't think things are
going to be turned around they're going
to go from bad
to worse and
i believe that we are living
in the very close of probation
where this final message goes to
humanity
and we've only just touched on the book
of revelation
chapter 11 and we will be going through
the rest of it and seeing
where exactly are we heading for but
we've been talking for quite a while now
so perhaps we should do that in the
following one
thank you yes will you close for us
please yes but before i do
please remember don't forget the
promises of god
don't only look at the doom and gloom
yes the doom and gloom is there
and retribution is coming
and we have been warned but
cling to the promises of god let's pray
heavenly father thank you for the
promises
in your word we know lord that
the time for this planet to be in
rebellion
is coming to an end and in a way we are
grateful for that
and we long for the restoration
of all that is holy and just
and good but we also know lord that
many many people and many people dear to
us
are trapped in this philosophy
and even if this philosophy should be
overthrown by the king of the north
many of them will be trapped again in
that philosophy not realizing that they
have escaped the frying pan only to end
in the fire
the deception runs so deep and i pray
that you will
grant wisdom so that people will see
through it and take their stand
upon the word of god as it stands and
not as it is interpreted
may they take their stand upon the
commandments of god
and the faith of jesus is my prayer in
jesus name
amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you